actress comedian Aubry Plaza Aubry I
understand you've turned into somewhat
of an LA Sparks fan over the past year I
am yes I come in last year my sister uh
had season tickets and uh so I started
coming with her it's awesome the
atmosphere and the energy of these games
what do you love the most about coming
to a Sparks game I just love watching
The Players uh it's inspiring they're so
good
um I yeah I just love watching them
they're so good now I know you played a
little bit of ball back in the day how
would you describe your game I
[Music]
constantly on the ball I was just crazy
I was uh yeah people hate me people
hated playing with me because I was all
over them that's when you know you're
doing something right Aubrey thanks so
much for joining us enjoy the game